logically how do you argue it goes from
day 39 not a life day 40 alive men and
women literally cannot understand each
other around this when life agrees with
me and every woman who works on this
show so let's go let's go let's say you
disagree with them listen to me I've had
two kids okay listen to me but you just
said men and women cannot agree my wife
and I agree and every woman on the show
men in women can't agree you and I don't
really glad to have her next this is a
return guest actually uh because people
with whom we disagree often don't come
back on the show despite us trying to be
as respectful as civil as possible it
doesn't matter sometimes it doesn't
matter it matters not so our next guest
very happy to have her back I read some
of her literature in college I believe
it yeah when I wasn't much so I've known
her for a long time it's like I've been
I've been peering she's been in a
fishbowl and I've been watching her for
a long time back in the college a so you
can follow her on the Twitter at me mayo
me are wolf and her website is daily
clout dot IO daily clout dot IO MS wolf
thank you for being back thank you so
much Steven I'm really happy to be here
well I'm glad I appreciate you coming
back and we were just talking before air
and you said that you got some positive
feedback last time even though we
disagreed right yes yeah no it was
really really nice I appreciate your
audience and I appreciated the
conversation there's so much polarized
kind of staged left versus right combat
in this country which is already divided
enough and your audience kept tweeting
me saying you know I didn't agree with a
lot of what you said but I appreciated
the the open dialogue you had with
Steven so that was cool yes it is very
and we actually we've invited actually
you're actually I hate to say a
replacement because you were busy when
we invited you I think recently and then
we had Maria del Russo invited back on
and should know and actually I think she
even got more positive feedback at the
end because it was her first time on air
so you never know sometimes people just
don't like a disagreement I've always
tried to be straightforward about this I
don't care about civility as much as
honesty but I try to afford it to
everybody but truth is what matters most
this bill in California now that would
force public colleges I think what is SB
I have it here somewhere on moment I
don't know there's a bill in California
I don't know the exact
people will fact-checking on it there's
a bill that will force public colleges
universities to provide abortion pills
up to ten weeks afterward to women now
there's been a lot of controversy about
this we've covered this on the on the
website and you actually in your site
which I which I very much admired had a
pro-life feminist organization post an
article and I know you've talked about
it in subsequent videos and podcasts
Senate bill three 20% it bill 320 there
we go yeah I was gonna get it wrong it
was 420 and then we're gonna get what no
now you have that wrong and then you
talk about even though you yourself are
pro-choice to use the term um what what
inspired you to do that um well so daily
clout is a platform that has gives
everyone the ability to search bills
like really just described and find you
know a whole set of them of I'm sorry of
bills by you know by by state or by
subject and then embed the actual live
bill in social media you can tweet this
bill for instance to you know your
networks in California if you want to
support or oppose the bill tweet the
bill sponsors so it's a way for all of
your audience and I really encourage
your audience to go to daily cloud IO
and use Bill camp to became become
lobbyists themselves and the reason I
wanted to showcase the president of
feminists for life talking about this
bill is a were nonpartisan but be you
know she has very powerful things to say
about why in her view this bill is not a
feminist bill and you know we welcome
anyone from any any political background
writing an op-ed about you know bills
that they can find in bill camera they
bills at the federal level or the state
level that they they want to lobby
around her position was that if we
really supported women you know we would
create conditions where no woman would
have to choose abortion so I'm pro-life
I don't agree with the policy
prescriptions that she what did I just
say oh my god
I'm technically pro-choice okay I was
confused and my follow up was about to
entirely change I'm pro-choice but that
was an interesting slip I really respect
the position
feminists for life because they are
unusual they really are feminists and
that's why you can't reduce feminism to
a simple set of positions they really
say all life is sacred they oppose the
death penalty they oppose you know
euthanasia
they are absolutely in favor of
everything that that supports life and
sustains life so they are very coherent
critique of abortion and you know their
view is let's make it if we really
cherished women and children women
wouldn't have to choose abortion yes
well I obviously listen shocker I'm
pro-life so I don't want you to feel
you're being sandbag I disagree with
their ideology their I think they're a
litany of reasons why I would and
particularly this bill but I would like
to for people who don't know know know
I'm pro-life I'm pro-life um so but I
would love for you to express your views
on abortion because I've heard you
express them I've seen you write about
them and you you do if I'm not mistaken
I want to make sure I understand it and
I'd like you to express it to the
audience because I do have some
questions you do believe that it is the
termination of a life but you are a
pro-choice but you want to reduce
abortion than you think it should be not
mistaken less celebrated than it is by
today's sort of progressive left if I've
gotten anything wrong please let your
views be represented by yourself sure
thank you so much so I mean it's such a
hard issue to talk about without being
reductive I did write an essay called
our bodies our souls in 1995 that was
very much taken up by the pro-life
movement in which I mean kind of this
argument I said and and I wrote it after
having been you know been pregnant and
had a baby and you know I'm still put
ice but after you are pregnant and have
a baby and you know you get to that
four-month period and the baby's like
leaping about there's literally no way
that you can pretend there's not a being
mm-hmm right and so it was a very
nuanced essay in which I basically said
the language
we're using an approach choice movement
around this issue is the wrong language
it's very reductive it's not just a
clump of cells it's not just a choice
it's a much more you know many women
experience it as a tragedy you know
where a lot I'm not saying they have to
but but just that is woman's experience
often and I just thought that the
discourse around the pro-choice movement
it was quite soulless and yeah you have
to face the fact that it is the
beginning of a life you know you can't
if you're pregnant and you're at six
weeks and the you know obstetricians
like oh the baby's doing great you know
if you don't want it's a condom so you
know we can't it can't be just dependent
on can I ask a couple of questions
because I find this I find this very
interesting I don't I don't agree with
you but I do find it interesting a
couple of things it sounds to me like
your position is much more that of
classical feminism which was abortion
should be safe legal and rare that was
the term we hear that was the what we
had heard repeated a lot and now it's
abortion on demand taxpayer-funded
period and you actually see people with
those signs that is the platform of the
DNC Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders may
but not yourself you cannot find anyone
in today's DNC who does not stand on
that position period they would be
considered an extremist whereas your
view seems to be more in line with
classical feminism so when that's the
position today when that's the policy
today when in places like Colorado
abortions occur up to 26 weeks but when
you see it seen as a travesty even in
Texas up to 20 weeks we're like well ha
a second this is a violation of women's
choice first question is when faced with
that what if we believe it's a life
what's wrong with being reductive if
it's a life it is reductive like okay I
said beginning of what will be a life if
it continues to you know the pregnancy
continues let me step back is you what I
really hate as a woman and and I'm just
being honest and I know you like it when
people are honest I really hate these
moments where especially a man says yeah
you have to choose you have to choose
right what's wrong with being reductive
and and whatever I'm asking a question I
don't know what's wrong with being
reductive when faced with the idea of
listen I believe it's a life so that is
that the argument is reductive and
that's not a negative thing it's a life
in my opinion and I'll defend it I'm
trying to say is if wherever as a
country gonna have really good policies
around the issue of unwanted pregnancies
we have to be a little more patient
because what women will say if you
really listen to them about this issue
takes a little longer and is more
nuanced okay though in my view I really
believe that categorically a woman needs
to be able to control her own body even
if that can lead to a very tragic choice
sometimes right she has to I believe
that in the first trimester there should
be no restrictions on a woman choosing
abortion on demand you know and that's
the situation in Europe and in most
civilized countries and it is
taxpayer-funded and also contraception
is taxpayer-funded and you would have
very you'd have half the number of
unintended pregnancies
if contraception was readily available
paid for by the government as it is all
over Europe in every same society we
have gotten off the libertarian beam so
let's make sure we're clear and that guy
was assuming we were starting from the
same premise now we're talking about
taxpayer-funded abortions contraception
so I I'm talking bear with me I mean the
most humane and enlightened pro-lifers
that I've spoken to you also want
contraception freely available
you know they it's much they see freely
I sure as much much morally better than
you know abortions right I mean they do
and I have to agree with them you know
really available of course I would never
restrict anyone's access to to purchase
contraception okay so whoever pays for
it I mean I personally think if you're
gonna have roads and you're gonna have
schools
you should have free condoms and
contraception but that is that you know
that would make so much of a better
society and a better planet but whatever
you're eating at that aside in Europe
after the first trimester it's much more
difficult to get an abortion and so they
don't have the passionate emotional wars
that we have here over second trimester
abortions right but what they do have is
a lot of support for them
there are a lot of options a lot of you
know government support if you are
having a baby that you can't look after
that you you can't afford okay um and so
to me that's a humane and and
libertarian you know solution because
you cannot have a society in which you
Steven
tell me Naomi that I can't control what
happens to my body you know within a
reasonable amount of time okay may I
respond to that
sure well no I just I don't you you you
you you you're you're very you're more
verbose than I am and I want to make
sure when I ask the questions that I can
ask them clearly so that we can get
clear answers and and and counter
answers um a couple of things I don't
think you can have a libertarian Society
where you Naomi force me to pay for your
abortion or contraception on the issue
of you know it being irritating when a
man forces I'm not forcing you to make a
choice an ideological choice here you
know my wife volunteers at a crisis
pregnancy center five days a week so and
I've done it as well this is but a
pro-life crisis pregnancy center so we
discuss the issue of choice there are
quite a few other choices we're off
there are five choices
there's abstinence there's contraception
and there's adoption and there's
motherhood
the only choice we're not okay with is
that that we believe to be and a lot of
course if I were talking in the case of
the mother because used to mention it's
freshening when a man explained so I'm
talking about from a mother's
perspective I absolutely think that we
should be encouraging young men to be
fathers and stop being deadbeats I think
that every child would benefit
tremendously from having both a positive
role model of a mother and a father on
that I'm sure we we can we can agree so
the question comes back to then at that
point we talked about nuance I it is
reductive if you believe it's a life so
my question I guess then becomes I
appreciate that you want this to be more
rare I appreciate that you don't
celebrate abortion as many people do
today and you understand that but I
don't think that it's intellectually as
tenable a position as the radical left
who believe taxpayer-funded on-demand
period unless you really clearly define
when is it a life and and that's the one
thing that I don't understand I don't
necessarily maybe
not informed on your argument when do
you believe it constitutes a life well I
guess there I don't have a simple answer
for you I mean Catholicism with no
disrespect to Catholicism has really you
know made this an either/or conversation
I'm Jewish and in the Jewish tradition
you have 40 days before it is a life and
that's true in Japan as well there are a
lot of cultures in which you have 40
days before that's considered even a
fetus you know and you've been pregnant
twice I can say that in the first 40
days you know whether its nature whether
its maternal instinct I I I'm glad I
never had to but I could have terminated
you know what was happening in the first
40 days and after that I couldn't you
know and that's a very subjective answer
but I do absolutely believe that you
know the first trimester especially you
know women really were supported in
finding out after they missed their
first menstrual cycle that they were
pregnant then they could have you know
terminations in the first six weeks and
that is by far the least I'm not saying
it's a great thing sure it is it is not
the same as carrying a baby in my mind
you as a mother it's not well but most
women don't know necessarily that a
pregnant was in the first 40 days so
health care for women they would find
out and you know before the second
menstrual cycle you know so that's the
first six weeks or eight weeks okay so
you believe we don't have health care
that's that's high-quality enough the
United States for people well I think
what I want to do Stephen yeah obviously
so a lot of women don't find out because
they're not seeing doctors they can't
afford doctors you know and a lot of
them are teenagers or a lot of them are
on you know I have drug issues or you
know
alcoholism issues uh or are homeless you
know and they find out very late or they
you know I'm talking about the average
one even an average healthy woman I mean
again listen we can we can get to these
extreme examples but if we want to find
common ground on the issue of abortion I
want to make sure that I'm clear so for
in your point of view forty days is the
cutoff am i understanding this I mean
I'd like to live in a society if I were
making policy right but this is just me
having traveled all over the world I
think a humane situation and one that
respects women's need to control their
own bodies their own reproduction which
categorically I believe in is is
Europe's where abortion really is you
know the after the morning-after pill is
readily available to women everywhere
for free it really is and failing that
and condoms and and free contraception
are available to everyone all the time
for free this is not a little thing
I had my commentators on daily cloud who
are in their 20s talk about a bill that
would make them pay for condoms and
contraception on college campuses and a
lot of even middle class and affluent
kids really can't afford to have
contraceptive sex it's really expensive
you know and so I'm sorry I can't I
can't this is especially can't go with
you in that prep premise you can get
condoms for 25 cents at a truck stop and
you can get countless generic birth
controls for under $14 at Walmart yes my
wife works at a crisis pregnancies there
are so many options this is why there
was the outrage with Hobby Lobby they
were offering offering I think 16 to 18
covered forms of contraception they just
didn't believe in the abortive again see
I I don't believe that I don't believe
that if you're having sex in 2018 and
you can't afford or know about
contraception that it's because of it's
from it's from a lack of trying
especially seeing women who come into
these crisis pregnancy centers most the
time it's just actually responsibility
statistically I respectfully you would
have liked my essay because I really do
believe that we all have to be
responsible for using contraception male
and female yeah but where feminism it
would be helpful to you right now is I
think you're not grappling with the fact
that a lot of women can't get their
partners to put on condoms and no I
don't think you're right that women can
find reliable contraception for $14 you
know where it's $14 you know a week
gravity let's round up to 50 let's run
up to 50 a month what but why are we
making it up if we know that the pill
can cost more than that we know that we
know that the pill can cost thousands of
dollars depending on what you're using
and we know that the pill can be as low
as four dollars or eight dollars with
generics you can go to Walmart right now
and get a generic birth
control pill for $8 12 if I'm being very
very generous you need you need a doctor
to prescribe it for eight a lot of women
can't afford to see doctors look how
many Americans don't have medical
insurance $50 cash $50 to go see a cash
doctor who can prescribe it and very
inexpensive I just don't go I just don't
go along that argument people tend to be
sexually or just like I don't go along
with absolving people responsibility if
you're with a guy who refuses to toss on
a rubber I believe that a woman should
be responsible enough to not be with
that guy and I believe that guy is a
germ he should be responsible enough to
put on a condom
she should be responsible enough to make
sure she's not with a guy who refuses to
put on a condom but again the this that
we're kind of getting off the track but
I want to see where we find that's okay
you're not getting off the track this
was another issue is the issue of life
and my question is which I find because
this is pivotal and we can't find common
ground under the guise of a lie and
that's the issue to where people say
well let's find common ground with pro
lifers but they don't listen to them
saying well on a second the only
consistent line of logic is that of
conception now we're so we're not
against contraception but the line of
conception so my question an example for
example would be why does it go from
being you said a woman's true it's her
body her choice well the woman doesn't
have 20 fingers and toes a woman doesn't
have four eyes if the boy has if it has
a penis the woman doesn't have a penis
this is a different body in her this is
not she is not choosing the point is
this is not her body this is a separate
body and a separate life
what for you logically how do you argue
it goes from day 39 not a life day 40
alive men and women literally when life
agrees with me and every woman who works
on this show so let's go let's go let's
say you disagree with them listen to me
I've had two kids okay
listen to me but you just said men and
women cannot agree my wife and I agree
and every woman on the show men and
women can agree you and I don't but all
right I'm sorry that was okay a fetus is
both a separate being and part of your
body and you you if you've never
experienced it you cannot understand
that it isn't it it is not separate from
your body it isn't and if it's not the
right time for you
have a baby and if you lived in a humane
society where you could terminate that
pregnancy before it's really a fetus I
you know there are many many
circumstances in which that that you you
know women have to be free to make that
choice it doesn't live on in a spaceship
it doesn't live without you know using
the mother's body as as its environment
as its host this is something we have to
grapple well then why does day 40 matter
at all sorry then why does this is why I
say that you're I understand your middle
ground is a more intellectually I
believe untenable position than even the
most radical feminist who believes until
it comes out of the womb if you use the
argument that it is a part of your body
it is not a separate life it is not a
separate part of your body it's an end
and sentence and what matters with day
40 I don't this is a logically why is
there a cut-off then because you're at
you know I'm trying to be really honest
with you you're asking for a black and
white answer and I don't have one what
I'm saying is you know in my fifty five
years on the planet having had two
children having traveled all over the
world having seen many many women's
lives who were ruined
a baby's lives were ruined by women not
being able to control their reproduction
I've lost you and that's okay no yes I
can hear you don't stress you can just
hit the button to resend us video it's
this is what happens with with phones
and big cities I blame big AT&T sorry
and you know and having thought deeply
about this issue we're not gonna have an
intellectually pure solution for any
policies because there aren't any but
what we are going to have is humane
policies that take into account women's
and babies needs and in my view a humane
society makes contraception readily
available gives women access to abortion
if they need it and the morning-after
pill in the first trimester and and you
know makes adoption really easy and and
and supports all children make sure
there's food and education and clothing
for all children so that you know more
women would not need to choose abortion
I'm with the pro-lifers on that and I'm
with approach choices on women really
needing to control their bodies at least
for the first trimester where
I don't know how to get you back oh that
well I just hit there's a little video
icon I believe little blue video icon um
I'm sure you can imagine where where I
would disagree with you not as a man
yeah but it intellectually along the
trail of there's nothing humane if there
we go
there's nothing humane if it's a life
and that's why I was so interested in
your actually you keep going back to the
male one and a control a woman there are
plenty of women half who agree with this
position that it is a life there is
nothing humane about ending another life
that is not your own the only question
that matters and this is one that I
think Naomi especially if you're talking
about a platform where you want to bring
people together you have no chance of
convincing someone who is pro-life and
certainly no chance of convincing the
radical feminists left today if you
cannot answer the question as to whether
it is a life or not and that's again why
I posit the only consistent line of
logic is conception otherwise there's no
difference at day 39 day 40 or exiting
the womb there's no difference so so I
I'm glad you brought this up I I'm I'm
gonna be a good daughter before Mother's
Day my mom is waiting for me to go join
her I'm out here visiting my parents so
I need to hop off but I will wrap up you
know or respond to it this is definite
you are absolutely right that I cannot
and will not give you a black and white
answer on this and that's because I have
a sense of integrity and my lived
experience as a woman and his mother as
a woman I cannot as a woman a sense of
integrity have an answer right tonight
if you were driving home and you thought
there were a dog in the road but you
weren't quite sure and you could slow
down you wouldn't kill the dog it's not
about you it's about the dog at that
point if you don't have an answer then
you can err on the side of not ending a
life is a dog I don't think these are
apples and oranges they're not the same
thing and I'm a very you know I have
religious faith I have reverence for all
life
I do not believe they are the same I
think that as the being develops mature
it becomes much more serious morally and
these are deep deep issues but it's
because they're deep issues I don't
think they should be reduced to sound
bytes I don't I don't know you should be
reduced to sound by Tina but I don't
think they should be reduced to policies
you just list it off by the way
completely anti libertarian about 12
that I counted policies which involved
my direct subsidized ation of someone
else's opinion despite the fact that
there is no answer there so if we don't
have an answer the libertarian in both
of us common ground would have to say
well we can't spend money on somebody
else's answer opinion and of course we
would have to err on the side of life if
we don't have an answer no not if we're
talking about a different different body
a different body with different DNA
different fingers toes eyes ears central
nervous system life that's a very
important argument well there you go up
until the womb but I know you have to go
thank you so much Naomi Wolf it is yes
well me let's get that website again one
more time sure it's daily clap dot IO so
come on we'd love to have you as a guest
on our platform 100% thank you so much
Naomi I appreciate it and I will
continue wrapping up here without you
because I know I know I appreciate being
good for Mother's Day and there we go
thank you knock hey Jared I would have
liked to have Naomi a bit longer and if
you have actually we'll have this in our
book that changed my mind the going on a
series of questioning so this is not me
fighting with windmills I just don't
feel it had necessarily consistent
answers there there is a line of
questioning that occurs when you say
well ok it's knit that's that's the
woman's body and she acted as though it
was absurd and feminists do this when
you say well does it does a woman have
how many toes does a woman have how many
how many ears how many hearts how many
kidneys
how many penises if it's a boy you have
to determine whether that is a life or
not and then again again it gets to the
essence of what is a life what
determines a life what is the essence of
a human all right this gets to the
Socratic method well the essence of a
human is what we're doing right now is
the ability to reason no animals are not
questioning this right now and I know
what you're saying you're saying well on
a second as I go doesn't have the
ability but it does have the potential
to develop into a human being who would
reason right in all of those human
zygotes all those clumps of human DNA
cells they
develop into apes they never develop
into dogs and they develop into cats
they develop into human beings so the
ability to rationalize the ability to
reason is what makes us distinctly human
and the potential to because a child who
can't reason yet who is one year old is
still a human we would not disagree
there that is what makes a human being a
human being on what determines a life
will that's what determines our life
the fact that you have unique DNA you
have a unique genetic code that has
formed the moment of conception and you
are ending that unique genetic code and
it's not your own it is entirely
separate from the mothers so this is not
a consistent line of logic and one thing
for me that I don't and I really do
appreciate no me Wolf's opinion at least
saying it shouldn't be celebrated that
it shouldn't be abortion on demand
period but if you listen to at the end
of it her argument ended up sliding that
way because your argument again the only
intellectually consistent argument she
can make is well it's in the womb so
it's a part of the mom okay
that then it's it's you can't justify
cutoff at 40 days there's certainly no
biological argument there's certainly no
scientific argument and there's no
pragmatic argument so if you get to it's
the woman's body listen first off first
argument you can't understand it as a
man that's a red herring there are
plenty of women who share this exact
same opinion okay I understand they have
a penis right now sitting in this chair
expressing this opinion but I'm not the
only one expressing it maybe we'll get a
female South host at some point then if
you get to the idea that is her body her
choice it's not her body it is another
body I've never heard a convincing
argument that it is in fact a part of
the mom's body and not a unique body and
then usually go Don down the trail to
viability well it's about it's about
viability
okay well viability is circumstantial a
baby today at Lenox Hill Hospital in
Manhattan is viable many many many many
weeks then only 50 years ago in the
hills of West Virginia day in the hills
of West Virginia let alone 200 years ago
does that mean one's of life and the
other one isn't why is one life more
valuable still not a clump Estelle's
still its own unique human being with
its own genetic code so is viability to
children toddlers they're not viable
what about older people who need to be
fed who need their diapers they're not
viable viability doesn't stand up to
reason and if if there is no argument
this is where we deal a lot with the
left and feminism and I very much
appreciate Noam and I would love to go
on her podcast I hope that
Jason was was genuine I will certainly
take her up on it um is not everything
as nuanced well use a term reductive as
though it's bad if you believe it's a
life as most people are pro-life do
that's the argument no other argument
matters and then of course we go on down
the trail to something which is
completely antithetical to
libertarianism which is the taxpayer
funding of abortion of contraception
based at predicated an idea which is
patently false that contraception is
outside the realm of affordability which
which statistically is not true that's
also not why most abortions are
performed okay so we're now so far off
the beam and we end up with well I don't
really have the answers so and it wasn't
so I don't have the answer so let's err
in the set of Liberty what was let's
look at what was how is Liberty defined
there by the feminists left today I
don't have the answer so they said let's
err on the side of Liberty well do you
mean Liberty and everyone having the
ability to determine their own life no
no I mean Liberty in the sense that a
woman has the right to terminate another
life and of course it has to be
taxpayer-funded or we hold a gun to your
head and say if you don't text if you
don't fund abortion and subsidize that
work we're going to force you to
subsidize contraception I don't believe
that the argument holds water you can
let me know if you think that it does I
wish we could have continued down this
trail with Naomi Wolf I didn't want to
interrupt her I didn't want her to get
aggravated I know a lot of the time she
she sees that as an aggressive male
posture but this is the same line of
questioning that I would ask anyone who
is I mean you can say pro-abortion
abortionists people who believe that
abortion is of more value than life if
you don't know it seems to me reasonable
to err on the side of life and if you
know tell me how you know hey if you
like this video subscribe or click the
notification but you should do both
anyways because youtube doesn't notify
you if you're just subscribed you have
to hit that notification bell so if you
already are subscribed hit the
notification bell and if you're not
supporting this content good a lot of us
kind of come slush mug clip you get the
full nightly show an hour every day free
when you subscribe this hand f-secure
theme ugh as well as other programming
and listen you also get to support not
caged yards Remicade treatment I don't
know what it is I know it has something
because he has he had all sort of
colitis it doesn't anymore thank God
because I removed his call
and truth be told it's not working very
well anyway